Hast du da einen Bildschirm über deiner Windschutzscheibe? Einen Bildschirm oben über deiner Windschutzscheibe? Busfahrer, was soll das? Ein Überwachungsbildschirm im Bus, das hat's doch früher nicht gegeben. Wo dein Bus doch längst ein Dach hat und eine Klimaanlage und eine digitale Haltestellenanzeige LED und einen Überwachungsbildschirm, der auf mehrere Kameras im Bus zugreifen kann und eine Rampe für Rollstühle. Ich bin behindert, aber ich kann trotzdem alles machen, was die anderen auch machen können, sogar in einen Bus einsteigen. Und alle denken sich, ja dann versuch's am besten gleich morgen mal mit Ski springen, hast du auch eine Rampe. Oh, muss ich sagen, Respekt!
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 168. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und weiter geht's bei CRE hier mit interessanten Themen aus Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Heute haben wir mal Technik und Gesellschaft ganz interessant zusammengebracht im Mittelpunkt des Gesprächs. Soll stehen ein Projekt namens wheelmap.org und was es damit auf sich hat und warum es das überhaupt alles gibt. Das erzählen uns heute gleich zwei Leute. Ich begrüße Rául Krauthausen. Richtig. Was für ein Zungenbrecher. Hallo Rául und Christoph, Christoph Bünte. Ja, ihr seid beide in diesem Projekt engagiert. Worum geht es? Also, das Ganze ist ja eine Art Geodienst für Leute, die mit dem Rollstuhl unterwegs sind. Damit fasse ich das Ganze mal ganz knapp und kurz zusammen, damit schon mal klar ist, worum es hier eigentlich gehen soll. Aber ich glaube, um das Ganze ein bisschen zu verstehen, müssen wir noch ein bisschen weiter ausholen. Rául, wir hatten ja schon mal ein Podcast zusammen, allerdings nicht auf dieser Schiene, sondern im Rahmen des Gesellschafterprojektes, was ich 2009 für die Aktion Mensch gemacht habe. Ausgabe Nummer 10, DG10, ging halt um dein eigentliches Metaprojekt, nämlich die Sozialhelden, denen ihr ja hier sozusagen beide angehört.
Genau.
Aber das müssen wir natürlich jetzt hier noch mal kurz zusammenfassen. Worum geht es in der ganzen Geschichte?
Bei den Sozialhelden jetzt?
Ja, bei den Sozialhelden. Ihr seid ja hier wohl mal wieder schuld.
Gut, die Sozialhelden gibt es seit 2004. Wir sind ein Verein, der versucht, auf innovative Art und Weise soziale Probleme zu bearbeiten, zu lösen oder zumindest Aufmerksamkeit für sie zu generieren. Und sind vielleicht bekannt dadurch geworden, dass wir in Supermärkten es etabliert haben, Pfandbongs zu spenden. In Berlin machen wir das mit Kaisers, in anderen Bundesländern mit EDEKA. Und die gespendeten Pfandbongs der Kunden gehen dann an Hilfsorganisationen in Berlin, zum Beispiel an die Berliner Tafel. Und das Projekt ist damals so groß geworden, oder ist so groß geworden, dass es 100.000 Euro im Jahr alleine für die Berliner Tafel generiert. Mit Pfandbongs, genau.
Also die Leute alles an Flaschen einkaufen und wieder zurückbringen.
Und selbst wenn nur jeder Zehnte seinen Bong einwirft, kommen halt 100.000 zusammen.
Habt ihr da mal eine Statistik gemacht, wie viele das denn nun wirklich tun?
Nein, wir haben jetzt einen Durchschnittswert, wie viel ein Kunde im Durchschnitt spendet. Das sind um die einen Euro. Also jemand, der Bongs einwirft.
Von jedem Kunden, den der Supermarkt hat oder von jedem, der...
Nee, von allen. Also wir erheben das pro Hilfsorganisation. Das heißt, wir sagen, bei der Berliner Tafel sind es dann 75 Cent pro...
Pro Bong, zu sagen.
Pro Spende.
Pro Spende, okay.
Das sind ja manchmal auch mehrere Bongs, die ein Kunde einwirft.
Interessant wäre ja sozusagen auch noch mal rauszukriegen, wie viele Leute von denen, die überhaupt im Supermarkt Flaschen zurückgeben, dann auch wirklich einen Bong einschmeißen.
Genau, aber da müsste man ja dann wirklich davor stehen und zählen.
Der Supermarkt muss ja eigentlich wissen, wie viele Bongs pro Tag eingelöst werden.
Es ist erstaunlich, wie rudimentär die Kassensysteme in Supermärkten sind. Also wie wenig da wirklich erfasst wird und wie viel dann auf der anderen Seite doch. Und dass jeder Supermarkt das auch anders macht, die teilweise sogar Franchising geführt sind, sodass es auch gar keine wirkliche Kontrollinstanz gibt, die dann von oben herab entscheidet, wir machen das so und so. Sondern einfach dann der Filialeiter, der vielleicht drei Filialen besitzt, das dann eigenmächtig entscheidet. Aber nur die Steuerstimmung so ungefähr. Gut, aber das ist eben, wie gesagt, eines der Projekte, mit denen wir Sozialhelden, ich würde mal sagen, uns einen Namen gemacht haben. Und wir verstehen uns aber eigentlich als ein Laden, der versucht, Projekte zu identifizieren, also Probleme zu identifizieren, daraus Projekte zu initiieren. Und wenn sie dann einigermaßen laufen, weiterzugehen, um neue Probleme zu identifizieren und Projekte zu machen. Und ein Projekt, das schon immer in meinem Kopf rumspukte, weil ich ja selber Rollstuhlfahrer bin, war, wie kann man es eigentlich Menschen im Rollstuhl vereinfachen, zu sagen, in welches Café, in welche Lokalität, bei welchem Arzt, bei welcher Tanzschule oder so, ich überhaupt reinkomme als Rollstuhlfahrer. Also ohne dass eine Wendeltreppe am Eingang ist oder keine Ahnung was, was für Rollstuhlfahrer einfach ein No-Go-Kriterium ist.
Tanzschule, was ist denn das für ein Beispiel?
Ja, ich habe halt versucht, die Bandbreite so breit wie möglich zu machen. Aber es gibt sowas halt immer für Ärzte. Es gibt sowas dann auch für Reha-Zentren und Krankenhäuser. Aber ich meine, Menschen im Rollstuhl wollen halt auch mehr. Die wollen halt nicht immer nur von Reha-Zentrum zur Sonderschule und zum Arzt gehen, sondern sie wollen eben auch mal in die Tanzschule, ins Café und vielleicht sogar Party im Berghain machen. Und dafür gab es so gut wie keine Daten für Menschen im Rollstuhl, um sich zu informieren. Es gibt vereinzelt Projekte in verschiedenen Städten, wo das dann die Behindertenbeauftragten der Stadtverwaltung versuchen zu erheben. Aber das sind halt Datensilos. Und ich hatte halt immer die Idee, man müsse es irgendwie online abbilden und jeder kann es eintragen, weil jeder Rollstuhlfahrer ja für seine Gegend sein Experte ist. Und bei 1,6 Millionen Rollstuhlfahrern in Deutschland könnte das ja eine ganz interessante Datenbasis ergeben, auf Dauer. Hinzu kommt, dass eben nicht nur Rollstuhlfahrer sich mit dem Thema Barrierefreiheit im weitesten Sinne auseinandersetzen, sondern vielleicht auch Eltern mit Kinderwagen oder überhaupt Freunde von Rollstuhlfahrern, die ja auch plötzlich einen Blick dafür bekommen, ob das Café, in dem sie gerne sind, einen zufälligen Stuf am Eingang hat oder nicht. Wir als Sozialeltern haben erst versucht, das Ganze selber zu initiieren mit unseren Leihenkenntnissen, haben mit Drupal experimentiert und versucht über guru.com uns Entwickler einzukaufen, die dann irgendwie unsere Module dafür programmieren. Und sind relativ schnell zu der Erkenntnis gekommen, dass es der Koordinationsaufwand und das, wie soll ich sagen, sich reinfrickeln in solche Projekte genauso teuer und genauso aufwendig ist, wenn du es im Ausland beauftragst, als wenn du in Deutschland versuchst, das mit Leuten zu machen, die du dafür begeistern kannst. Und hatten selber relativ viele schmerzliche Erlebnisse beim Scheitern einer Drupal-Installation, die dann beim nächsten Update einfach zerschossen war, weil wir einfach so viele selbstgefrickelte Module hatten, dass wir gesagt haben, so geht das nicht. Und kamen dann nach und nach auf den Trichter, dass man vielleicht auf bestehende Communities aufsetzen muss. Also natürlich gab es immer Google Maps und Bing Maps und wie die alle heißen. Aber was wir halt komplett gar nicht auf dem Schirm hatten, war die OpenStreetMap. Und als wir uns dann aber näher mit dem Thema OpenStreetMap beschäftigt haben, haben wir gesagt, das ist die Technologie, auf die wir setzen wollen. Und hatten natürlich noch weniger Ahnung von dieser Materie. Und haben dann wirklich aktiv versucht, uns in dem Bereich Leute zu suchen. Und glücklicherweise Christoph am Ende gefunden, der uns wirklich dann auch in der Hinsicht die Expertise bringt, um dieses OpenStreetMap-Phänomen und auch die Technologie dahinter zu verstehen. Und wir als Sozialhelden eher versuchen, zu missionieren im Sinne der Datenbeschaffung für die OpenStreetMap.
Aber Christoph ist ja jetzt auch sozusagen Sozialheld. In dem Moment, wo man sich in eurer Sphäre begibt, ist man ja auch gleich Teil vom Club, oder?
Genau. Wir sind zwar ein eingetragener Verein, aber wir haben in unserer Satzung stehen, bzw. in unserem Manifest, dass wir es nicht zur Bedingung machen, Vereinsmitglied zu werden, sondern einfach das Engagement zählt. Und jeder, der Sicherheit bei uns einbringt, kann sich automatisch Sozialheld nennen, weil wir den Namen Sozialheld auch gar nicht so ernst nehmen. Also Sozialheld ist für uns mehr so ein, wie soll ich sagen, ein Aufmerksamkeitserreger. Also der Name bleibt einfach hängen. Aber es ist auch ganz viel Ironie mit drin. Also wir sich selber als Held zu bezeichnen, ist unter Umständen extrem arrogant. Und genau mit diesem Trick wollen wir halt auch spielen. Eigentlich ist meine feste Überzeugung und auch die von allen, die bei uns dabei sind, dass jeder ein Held ist, automatisch. Und Sozialheld eigentlich nur sagt, dass wir uns nicht mit Umweltthemen beschäftigen, sondern mit sozialen Themen. Sonst wären wir halt Umwelthelden. Andere sind Computerhelden und wir sind halt die Sozialhelden.
Ja, Christoph, wir sind ein bisschen dazu gestoßen. War das schon immer dein Thema?
Ich bin dazu gekommen wie die Jungfrau aus dem Kind. Ehrlich gesagt, der Holger hatte mich angesprochen, Rául zu Freund. Mit ihm hatte ich zusammen bei Moviepilot gearbeitet. Und er hat gesagt, Christoph, wir haben noch immer super zusammen gearbeitet, hast du nicht Lust, mal was zu machen? Wir machen hier eine Karten-Applikation. Und ich hatte von OpenStreetMap keine Ahnung, von OpenLayers keine Ahnung. Ich hatte das Einzige, was ich konnte, war Ruby und Rails. Und er hat gesagt, klar, probieren wir es einfach. Und nach, weiß nicht, zwei Wochen Einarbeitung, irgendwie befassen mit der Materie, war da schon ein ganz gutes Ergebnis zustande gekommen. Womit wir zwar alle noch nicht so richtig zufrieden waren, aber es war erstmal was, was man vorzeigen konnte und dem man die Idee vermitteln konnte, wie soll es sich letztendlich mal anfühlen. Die erste Version hat 50 Sekunden gebraucht, bis die Webseite geladen war, hat so viel Last auf dem Server erzeugt, dass der Hoster, wir sind bei Rocket Rentals freundlicherweise gehostet, uns gesagt hat, du müsst da irgendwas machen, das geht so nicht. Ihr liegt den Server lahm, die Webseite stinkt langsam, also ihr müsst euch da noch ein bisschen reinknien. Und ja, so ist es Stück für Stück immer besser geworden.
Wie ist denn das eigentlich so mit dieser ganzen, wie barrierefrei ist denn so unsere urbane Umwelt? Ich meine, man muss ja überhaupt erstmal so ein bisschen, was muss man sich als Nicht-Rollstuhlfahrer da denn so mal vergegenwärtigen, mit welchen Augen muss man denn da schauen?
Ja, also das Interessante ist, dass es uns auch, also ich bezeichne mich selber gar nicht als Berufsbehinderten. Das heißt, ich sitze zwar im Rollstuhl, aber ich versuche irgendwie trotzdem Leben zu leben, wie viele andere auch und arbeite auch bisher in einem Beruf, der nichts mit meiner Behinderung im Kern zu tun hat. Das heißt, ich sitze zwar im Rollstuhl an meinem Arbeitsplatz, aber der Arbeitsplatz hat nichts mit meinem Rollstuhl zu tun.
Das ist ja auch Medienfuzzi, ne?
Und wir haben bei der Arbeit jetzt rund um Wheelmap festgestellt, dass Barrierefreiheit ein extrem großer Begriff ist. Das heißt, Barrierefreiheit bedeutet in dem Fall nicht nur, Rollstuhlfahrer brauchen einen ebenerdigen Eingang oder einen Aufzug, sondern es bedeutet eben auch, Blinde brauchen im Café eine Karte mit Breiheulschrift, Gehörlose brauchen Dolmetscher in Gebärdensprache unter Umständen und Menschen mit Lernschwierigkeiten brauchen einfache Sprache. Das heißt, man ist ganz schnell auf einem richtig krassen Film drauf, dass wir dann auch das Wording bei Wheelmap geändert haben und gesagt haben, wir reden eigentlich eher von Rollstuhlgerechtigkeit. Das heißt, wir versuchen erst einmal das eine Problem für Menschen mit Rollstuhlfahrern zu bearbeiten, weil wir davon ausgehen, dass wenn wir eine Karte machen würden für Blinde zum Beispiel, dass ganz andere Bedürfnisse am Ende auch erfordert oder dahinterstecken, man das nicht mit der gleichen Technologie eins zu eins abfrühstücken könnte. Also lange Rede kurzer Sinn, um die Welt rollstuhlgerecht zu haben, um das jetzt mal auf das runterzubrechen, ist es natürlich für Menschen im Rollstuhl wichtig, dass sie selbstständig reinkommen, also selbstbestimmt, dass sie nicht immer um Hilfe fragen müssen, um diese drei, zwei Stufen zu überbrücken, was teilweise auch gar nicht geht, wenn man mit einem elektrischen Rollstuhl unterwegs ist, dass die Tür vielleicht nicht allzu schmal ist. Ich will mich da jetzt nicht auf Zentimeter festlegen, weil ich davon ausgehe, dass Rollstuhlhersteller Standard-Türbreiten berücksichtigen, wenn sie Rollstühle bauen.
Davon gehst du aus oder weißt du, dass dem so ist?
Es ist natürlich auch so. Es gibt natürlich Spezial-Rollstühle für Menschen mit besonderen Einschränkungen, die breitere Rollstühle erfordern. Aber die haben dann grundsätzlich auch noch viel mehr Herausforderungen zu bewältigen im Alltag. Wenn wir jetzt deren Maßstäbe nehmen würden, würden wir viel mehr Orte als nicht rollstuhlgerecht markieren. Wir versuchen, nach gesundem Menschenverstand sollte ein rollstuhlgerechter Eingang entweder einen Aufzug haben, eine Rampe haben oder keine Stufe am Eingang haben. Ob die Türbreite jetzt 90 oder 1,10 Meter ist, kann man dann auch noch eintragen, ist aber jetzt keine kritische Information. Vielleicht, wenn sie nur 10 cm breit ist, dann wird es irgendwie kritisch.
Das ist nicht nur nicht rollstuhlgerecht, sondern wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht kundengerecht.
Genau. Wenn du jetzt die Frage beantwortet haben willst, wie rollstuhlgerecht ist eigentlich diese Welt, ich habe neulich gehört, Bielefeld ist angeblich eine der rollstuhlgerechtesten Städte Deutschlands. Einfach weil da relativ viel Neubauten sind. Fast alle Geschäfte in der Einkaufsstraße ebenerdig. Was natürlich in Städten wie Berlin, die viele Altbauten haben, wo man einfach damals gesagt hat, Hochparteier ist wichtig wegen den Ratten, was auch immer, wegen der matschigen Straße. Das ist natürlich jetzt schwieriger für Menschen im Rollstuhl. Was aber Berlin ganz gut geregelt hat, ist zum Beispiel, bis auf die Ausnahmen mit defekten Aufzügen und so weiter, dass der öffentliche Personennahverkehr inzwischen fast weitestgehend rollstuhlgerecht ist. Das heißt, alle Busse haben jetzt Rampen, wirklich 100%.
Wirklich alle?
Was aber nicht nur daran liegt, dass sie gesagt haben, wir werden jetzt rollstuhlgerecht. Das liegt vor allem daran, dass die neue EU-Abgasnorm natürlich dazu führte, dass die BVG neue Busse kaufen musste. Und diese neuen Busse haben alle standardmäßig Rampen. Und das war dann praktisch der second win. Womit sie sich noch sehr schwer tun, sind Aufzüge an U-Bahnhöfen. Da ist die S-Bahn weiter. Aber diese Dinger müssen halt auch gewartet werden. Und wenn die dann kaputt sind, hat man halt Pech. Das heißt, ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus, und da bin ich glaube ich relativ tolerant, dass Berlin mit den öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln relativ gut erschlossen ist für Rollstuhlfahrer. Und wir dann eben gesagt haben, aber wir brauchen trotzdem noch die Information, komme ich als Rollstuhlfahrer überhaupt in einen Ort rein. Also lohnt sich der Weg, sage ich mal. Und dazu gibt es relativ wenig Information.
Aber wenn du jetzt von A nach B willst, was weiß ich, also da gibt es ein Meeting von einer interessanten Gruppe, die trifft sich irgendwie in einer Kneipe, das ist dann irgendwie so 19 Uhr, tralala. Was sind denn alles die Dinge, die du sozusagen checken musst, um entscheiden zu können, dass du daran teilnehmen kannst oder nicht? Womit fängt das an?
Okay, also es fängt damit an, dass ich auf meinen BVG-Plan gucke. Wo ist der nächstgelegene S-Bahnhof, der einen Aufzug hat? Das wäre der erste Schritt. Oft ist es damit verbunden, dass man entweder zwei Bahnhöfe weiter früher aussteigen muss oder später. Ganz besonders tricky die U1, die nur an jeden fünften Bahnhof aufzuckert. Und gerade an Knotenpunkten wie Warschauer Straße, keine existiert für die S-Bahn. Die U-Bahn hat einen, die S-Bahn nicht. Das heißt, es gibt Mischbahnhöfe, wo dann eben nur eines dieser beiden Verkehrsmittel holstuhlgerecht zugänglich ist. Das muss man als Rollstuhlfahrer irgendwann wissen, welche Routen halt gehen. Und dann der zweite Schritt, den ich mache, ist, dass ich dann meistens zu spät, also erstmal unterwegs, gucke, ob die Aufzüge funktionieren. Ich vergesse es einfach oft, zu gucken vorher. Da gibt es aber Websites von der S-Bahn und der BVG, die wir auch auf Wheelmap verlinkt haben, wo man gucken kann, ob ein Aufzug gerade funktioniert oder eben nicht.
Aber in Echtzeit werden diese Informationen nicht maschinenlesbar zur Verfügung gestellt?
Das sind einfach ganz simple HTML-Tabellen, wo dann einfach steht, defekt nicht defekt.
Wo irgendjemand das da so reintippt.
Ja, die behaupten zwar, dass sie das teilweise automatisiert hinkriegen, weil die Aufzüge wohl im 5-Minuten-Takt ein Signal schicken, ich funktioniere, und wenn das Signal eben nicht kommt, dass das dann automatisch irgendwie bei den Lämpchen angeht. Was ich aber bezweifle, weil relativ häufig ich der Erste bin, der defekte Aufzüge meldet.
Ich meine, wenn es diesen Datastream gibt, dann wäre das ja vielleicht mal ganz interessant, den zu kriegen.
Ja, richtig. Aber das Problem ist, gerade bei der S-Bahn in Berlin, dass die Aufzüge nicht der S-Bahn gehören. Also das sind auch sehr, Deutschland ist ja ein Meister da drin, Sachen auszusorgen, also sie gründen große Konzerne, das nennt sich dann Deutsche Bahn AG, die dann Tochterkonzerne haben, die dann S-Bahn Berlin GmbH heißt, der dann die Gleise und die Waggons gehören. Aber die Bahnhöfe gehören der Deutschen Bahn Stations and Services AG, die in Frankfurt am Main sitzt. Und die schieben die Verantwortung ständig sich gegenseitig zu. Das heißt, die defekten S-Bahn-Aufzüge müssen in Frankfurt gemeldet werden, die dann in Berlin eine Firma beauftragen, diese Dinger zu reparieren. Und wenn man dann fragt, warum sind die eigentlich immer kaputt, dann behaupten sie, es wäre der Vandalismus. Was ich aber nicht bestätigen kann, weil ich einen ganz expliziten Aufzug täglich benutze und der einfach nie beschädigt wurde durch Menschen, sondern einfach weil, vielleicht witterungsbedingt, oder weil der Mechaniker irgendwie vergessen hatte, da irgendwie den Schalter umzulegen, alles ist schon vorgekommen. Und die Dinger werden halt auch nicht wirklich gewartet in meinen Augen, sondern die S-Bahn wird immer nur dann aktiv, wenn die Dinger kaputt sind. Und dann tauschen sie die aus. Jetzt gerade, S-Bahnhof Griebnitzsee, ist dann also für zwei Monate kein Aufzug vorhanden, weil das Ding ausgetauscht wird, wo man sich auch fragt, warum dauert sowas zwei Monate? Also in jedem anderen normalen Haus, Hochhaus, am besten noch Bürogebäude, ist dieses Ding in einer Woche repariert oder neu installiert. Bei dem Bau dauert es zwei Monate.
Ist denn das bei euch schon eigentlich ein Teil der Überlegung, sozusagen den aktuellen Funktionszustand von Fahrstühlen zu erfassen?
Es ist extrem auffällig wahrscheinlich. Den Stream muss man erstmal haben, die Information.
Den Stream kann man ja selber erzeugen.
Wobei die Daten, die bei der S-Bahn drinstehen, handisch eingegeben werden.
Ich rede jetzt gar nicht von den Daten, die man von der vielleicht bekommen könnte, aber dann nie kriegt, weil sie das nicht geben wollen, weil sie das nicht hinkriegen, sondern wenn Leute, die einfach diesen Fahrstuhl defekt vorfinden oder auch im Betrieb vornehmen, vorfinden, das melden. Wobei der Fahrstuhl funktioniert.
Klar, das kann man jetzt schon machen. Also man kann halt sagen, dieser Aufzug ist jetzt gerade nicht Rollstuhl-gerecht. Dieser Bahnhof meine ich. Aber das sind ja sehr kurzweilige Informationen. Weil die Dinger werden ja dann vielleicht hoffentlich innerhalb von 24 Stunden repariert, wenn es ein kleiner Schaden ist. Und du musst ja dann dafür sorgen, dass das Ding wieder...
Na gut, wenn man da eine entsprechende Datenbank hat, dann könnte man ja auch sagen, wenn jemand etwas als defekt meldet, dann ist es jetzt erstmal für 8 Stunden als defekt gespeichert. So nach dem Motto. Vor so und so vielen Stunden ist er als defekt gemeldet worden. Da kann sich ja jeder selber einen Reim drauf machen. Wenn du so die durchschnittliche Reparaturturnaround-Zeit kennst, dann weißt du, naja, vielleicht sollte ich dann doch mal einen anderen Bahnhof nehmen.
Interessant wäre dann, diesen Stream gleich an die S-Bahn zu schicken. Automatisierend.
Ja, vor allem dann auch gleich den passenden Internetpranger dazu zu realisieren, wo man dann sozusagen die durchschnittliche Defekt-Time der Fahrstühle ausrechnet und dann sozusagen von Rot ins Grün Lämpchen wandern lässt.
Ich glaube, da wäre es sogar noch einfacher, um diese Daten zu generieren, diese durchschnittliche Defekt-Time einfach einen Crawler über die Seite der S-Bahn laufen lassen, der einfach guckt, wie lange steht denn eigentlich etwas da drin als Defekt?
Als Vergleich. Ja, aber man muss ja auch sozusagen mal die Wahrheit noch daneben. Genau. Wahrheit und Propaganda miteinander vergleichen.
Also ich glaube, da gibt es auf jeden Fall eine Menge Eskalationspotenzial.
Okay, aber ich wollte jetzt nicht schon gleich hier in die Fitschrittes ausbrechen, das kann ich nur gerade, bevor ich es wieder vergesse. Aber wir waren ja sozusagen immer noch unterwegs. Also du musst erst mal planen, wo kann ich überhaupt langfahren? Welche Bahnhöfe, die in Frage kommen, sind überhaupt rollstuhlgerecht und können mich da hinbringen?
Genau.
Und dann gehen wir mal jetzt davon aus, du hast so eine Route gefunden und alle Fahrstühle funktionieren?
Dann fahre ich in der Regel...
Also wir sind ja immer noch bei der Planung deiner Reise. Also wessen musst du dich sozusagen versichern, um zu wissen, dass du da überhaupt dann teilnehmen kannst.
Okay, also angenommen wir fahren an einen Ort, wo ich nicht weiß, ob dieser Ort rollstuhlgerecht ist oder nicht. Da gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten dieses Problems zu lösen. Entweder ich fahre mit meinem kleinen Rollstuhl, der aber erfordert, dass ich geschoben werde, dass ich die Treppen gegebenenfalls hochgetragen werde. Ich also nicht selbstbestimmt unterwegs bin. Oder aber ich versuche vorab zu klären, ob ich mit meinem elektrischen Rollstuhl dorthin komme. Das bedeutet eben, wie gesagt, ich gucke, welcher Bahnhof hat einen Aufzug bzw. welche Bus fährt wo lang. Ich bin inzwischen voll der Bus-Experte geworden, weil Busse ja mein Geheimverkehrsmittel geworden sind. Und gucke, ob die Aufzüge funktionieren. Und rufe dann bei der Location an, ob der Eingang stufenlos erreichbar ist oder wie auch immer. Ob es irgendeinen Hintereingang gibt, wobei diese Information nicht immer funktioniert, weil die Leute dann am Telefon sagen, ja, ja, wir sind rollstuhlgerecht, wir haben nur fünf Stufen am Eingang. Also ich versuche noch irgendwie die richtige Frage zu stellen, dass die Leute irgendwie darauf kommen. Also inzwischen frage ich, ob der Eingang stufenlos ist, was auch nicht immer hilft, weil sie dann vielleicht, keine Ahnung, stufenlos man vielleicht reinkommt, aber dann doch hinten irgendwie eine Wendeltreppe in den eigentlichen Partyraum geht oder so. Genau, und das muss man halt im Vorfeld rausfinden. Die verlässigste Quelle in dem Zusammenhang sind Freunde, die da vielleicht schon mal waren, die sich im Groben daran erinnern. In den USA gucken viele bei Google Street View, ob der Eingang halt eine Stufe hat oder nicht. Das ist eine sehr interessante Informationsquelle auf jeden Fall.
In Deutschland darf man das natürlich nicht, das ist ja alles schwarz.
Das ist ja alles verpixelt, genau.
Ja, das ist ja auch alles ganz böse. Ja, interessant, wenn man jetzt irgendwie öffentliche Gebäude, wo tatsächlich so Kneipen und so weiter sind, wenn dann irgendein Heini der Meinung ist, er müsste jetzt bei Google Street View dann mal widersprechen und die Daten rausnehmen.
Also wir haben auf jeden Fall in die Wheelmap auch schon ein Street View-Fenster implementiert. Das heißt, sobald Street View am Start ist...
Verstehe, kann man das dann einfach zusätzlich mit einblenden?
Genau. Weil wir einfach davon ausgehen, das ist eine interessante Information für Rollstuhlfahrer.
Ja, das war's schon sozusagen. Also das sind so die... Eigentlich geht es nur um Stufen. Und um Türbereiten vielleicht noch und Fahrstühle.
Ja, und wenn man ganz ins Detail gehen will, vielleicht noch um die Toilette.
Ja, hätte ich jetzt als nächstes gefragt.
Genau.
Das ist ja nicht ganz unwichtig, oder?
Richtig, richtig, es ist nicht ganz unwichtig, aber manchmal geht man ja nicht immer auf Toilette. Oder man muss nicht überall auf Toilette gehen können. Es gibt Orte, die haben gar keine Toilette, beispielsweise. Und ich glaube, dass bei einem Café es wichtiger ist, einen Café zu bekommen, als auf Toilette gehen zu können.
Na ja, gut, aber ich meine, das Problem kann ja nun auch entstehen.
Ja, genau, es bedingt sich dann halt. Deswegen gibt es auf der Wheelmap die Möglichkeit zu sagen, dieser Ort ist teilweise rollstückgerecht. Das bedeutet, ich bekomme zwar ein Café im Café, aber eben die Toilette ist nicht rollstückgerecht. Und es gibt aber natürlich auch Cafés wie Starbucks, McDonalds, die da irgendwie jetzt ein bisschen mehr Bewusstsein für haben, die das dann auch standardmäßig machen.
So, dann kommen wir vielleicht noch mal auf den eigentlichen Kern hier der ganzen Geschichte. Also eure Idee war, eine Datenbank zu bauen, eine Geodatenbank, um eben all diese für Rollstuhlfahrer relevanten Informationen zu sammeln. Und über kurz oder lang seid ihr da auf OpenStreetMap gekommen. Ich würde fast sagen, das ist schon ein No-Brain-er, aber ihr habt eine Weile gebraucht dafür, oder?
Ja, weil wir einfach aus dem Problem heraus gedacht haben und nicht aus der Technik heraus. Also aus der Technik heraus werden wir relativ schnell darauf gekommen. Wir hatten das auch vor Jahren schon mal gehört, dass es das gibt. Es ist nur, wir haben selber auch nicht die Expertise gehabt, zu gucken, ist das überhaupt von der Performance her machbar? Und hatten uns ja auch da am Anfang ein bisschen verhoben, sodass es im Nachhinein auf jeden Fall der richtige Schritt war, auf die OpenStreetMap zu setzen. Erstens, weil sie extrem schnell wächst. Zweitens, weil die Daten gemeinfrei sind. Und drittens, weil jeder da reintragen kann. Also das ist ja der absolute Wahnsinn. Und ich bin inzwischen der totale OpenStreetMap-Fan und bereue, kein bisschen darauf gesetzt zu haben.
Ja Christoph, da kommst du so ein bisschen ins Spiel. Du bist dann sozusagen mit Schuld gewesen für diese Entscheidung oder war dir zu dem Zeitpunkt schon gefallen?
Als ich dazugestoßen bin, war die schon gefallen. Letztlich hat der Nico Hagenburger, auch ein Rails-Entwickler hier in Berlin, die erste Version entwickelt. Das Grundgerüst stand und letztlich die Designentscheidung dort, mit der OpenStreetMap-Datemark zu arbeiten. Die ursprüngliche Idee war, dass man alle Daten, die man dort anzeigen will, über eine API anzapfen kann in Echtzeit. Das würde alles ganz einfach funktionieren. Man bräuchte vielleicht gar nicht eine eigene Datenmark. Weil man will ja nicht so Synchronisierungsprobleme haben. Welche Daten behält man? Welche schickt man zurück? Die Idee war einfach, wir zapfen es für jeden User an aus einer API. Und wenn das speichert, schicken wir es gleich wieder zurück. Und wir haben gar keine lokale Datenmark. Der Zahn wurde uns schnell gezogen, als dann halt mitunter die API mal drei Tage nicht verfügbar war. Oder aber einfach 50 Sekunden brauchte, um zu antworten.
Also theoretisch geht das sozusagen bei OpenStreetMap. Aber praktisch geht es manchmal einfach nicht wegen Bodennebel.
Und das war für uns letztlich ein No-Go. Wir haben dann den Frederik Ramm von der Geofabrik gebeten, uns dort ein bisschen auf die Sprünge zu helfen, wie wir eine eigene Datenbank so synchron halten mit der OpenStreetMap-Datenbank, dass wir die sozusagen lokal verfügbar haben, aber trotzdem Daten erheben können und Daten wieder zurückspielen in die OpenStreetMap, aber halt quasi kein Synchronisierungsproblem in dem Sinne haben. Also wir schreiben in unsere eigene Datenbank nie rein, sondern wir schreiben immer zur OpenStreetMap zurück und replizieren dann im 2-Minuten-Takt die OpenStreetMap-Datenbank wieder zurück in unsere lokale Datenbank.
Aber wenn die mal 3 Tage nicht läuft, dann geht das natürlich auch nicht, oder?
Das geht nicht über diese API, die wir damals benutzt hatten, sondern die ist relativ zuverlässig, die wir jetzt haben, diese Standard-Abfrage-Mechanismus. Die nennt sich Osmosis, das Tool, sinngebenderweise, und diffundiert quasi Datendifferenzen in unsere Datenbank rein. Das läuft echt ohne Probleme.
Kannst vielleicht noch mal kurz mal klarmachen, wie eigentlich sozusagen die aktuelle Topologie dabei OpenStreetMap ist. Also wo sind welche Daten und an welche Daten kommt man, auf welche Art und Weise ran und welche dieser Optionen sind für euch entscheidend. Also ich hab ja auch gleich hier nochmal platzieren. Gerade mit dem von euch erwähnten Friedrich Gramm und seinem Kollegen Jochen Topf von der Geofabrik vor einiger Zeit hier schon mal bei CRE eine Sendung gemacht zur OpenStreetMap. Vor einiger Zeit heißt März 2009. Da hat sich viel getan in diesem Projekt. Von daher ist wahrscheinlich schon wieder alles outdated. Chaosradio Express 113, OpenStreetMap. Aber vielleicht jetzt mal aus dieser Anwendersicht sozusagen. Was muss man quasi bedenken und welche Realitäten herrschen davor, wenn man da jetzt mit so einem Projekt ran geht?
Also als Anwender oder als Nutzer von einer API war es am Anfang ein bisschen undurchsichtig, welche Datenquellen können wir nehmen, welche können wir anzapfen und so weiter. Und es gab auf alle Fälle die Standard OpenStreetMap-API, die ist auch zuverlässig und schnell, aber die war für unsere Zwecke nicht geeignet, weil man Daten nicht nach Bounding Box filtern kann. Das heißt, man kann entweder sich alle Notes geben lassen oder nur einen Note, aber nicht, gib mir alle Points of Interest in einem bestimmten Rechteck auf der Karte. Also ein Note ist alles Mögliche? Alles Mögliche.
Kann eine Straße sein, kann ein Haus sein, kann ein Baum sein?
Es kann ein Baum sein oder ein Haus in dem Sinne nicht. Die OpenStreetMap unterscheidet zwischen Notes, Ways und Relations. Eine Straße ist letztendlich ein Way, bestehend aus mehreren Way-Punkten, die aber in einer Relation wieder zusammengefasst ist und die dann auch deklariert wird, dass es eine Straße ist. Die hat auch eine Fahrtrichtung und die kann auch andere Attribute haben, dass es eine Bundesstraße ist oder eine Straßennamme. Genau, maximale Geschwindigkeit. Letztlich hat ein Way und ein Note immer Tags. Tags können alles sein. Es gibt eigentlich keine Restriktionen. Du kannst alles an diese Notes ranhängen. Letztlich gibt es aber doch sinngebenderweise, wie nennt man das, allgemeine Regeln, Konventionen, welche Tags man verwenden sollte. Zum Beispiel für einen Shop oder für Shops à la Art heißt der Tag Shop. Und das Attribut dafür ist dann halt Bakery oder eine Wäscherei. Unter anderem gibt es auch einen Tag namens Wheelchair. Und das bezeichnet die Rollstuhlgerechtigkeit eines Ortes. Der hat letztlich vier Ausprägungen. Das ist Yes, No, Limited oder Unknown.
Das habt aber nicht ihr definiert, sondern das gab es schon.
Genau, das waren vor uns schon definiert. Und es wurde auch benutzt, ganz offensichtlich. Und mit diesen Daten, Limited und Unknown.
Wobei jeder Ort, der keinen Wheelchair-Tag hat, automatisch auch als Unknown interpretiert wird. Was wir aber auch gemacht haben, in der Vorfeldarbeit, uns mit der Community auseinanderzusetzen, machen diese Kategorien Sinn. Und wann ist denn etwas Limited und wann nicht? Mit der OpenStreetMap-Community. Wir haben uns dann praktisch im einvernehmen auf bestimmte Attribute geeinigt. Das ist ja das Spannende an der OpenStreetMap, dass dann auch wirklich international verwendet werden, solange bis sich die Regeln meinetwegen ändern. Das heißt, es gibt ein Projekt in Italien, dass die gleichen Tags verwendet. Wenn man in Italien Wheelmap aufrufen würde, dann würde anhand der IP-Adresse der Ort in der Mitte stehen, an dem man sich befindet. Die gleichen Informationen würden angezeigt werden, wie hier in Deutschland, einfach weil wir uns an die gleichen Regeln gehalten haben. Das ist das Spannende. Man kann gar nicht sagen, ob Wheelmap ein Projekt für Deutschland ist, oder nur für Becker, oder nur für was auch immer, sondern es ist ein globales interstellares Unternehmen. Da, wo es verwendet wird, funktioniert es. Da, wo Daten erhoben werden, funktioniert es. Wir haben initial versucht, zu gucken, was überhaupt Orte sind, die für Rollstuhlfahrer interessant sind. Es sind natürlich, wie soll ich mal sagen, Denkmäler. Ein Denkmal im Kleistpark. Kann man natürlich jetzt als Rollstuhlgericht markieren oder nicht. Oder eine Ampel. Es ist nur vielleicht nicht ganz so relevant, wie das Café Kleister oder was auch immer. Wir haben versucht, mal eine Liste zu machen. Wie viele Orte waren es? Und am Ende 100. Oder 100 Arten von 100 Typen.
Wirklich? So viele?
Ja, wir haben alles drin. Polizeistation, Feuerwehrstation, Krankenhausarzt, Tierarzt. Da kommt man relativ schnell in sehr kleine Details.
Wobei die Anzahl von nicht-rollstuhlgerechten Krankenhäusern dürfte sich ja wahrscheinlich in Grenzen halten.
Richtig, aber Tierärzte sind dann wieder eine interessante Information. Obwohl man bei der OpenStreetMap irgendwie alles eintragen kann, haben wir jetzt erstmal für uns 100 definiert, die jetzt interessant sind. Die, wenn wir sie erheben, auch in die OpenStreetMap zurückgehen. Aber irgendwie eine Gießkannen-Auffüllstation auf dem Friedhof eher nicht.
Ihr habt ja, das kann ich ja gleich vorwegnehmen, so eine iPhone-Applikation auch in Entwicklung zum Zeitpunkt dieses Gesprächs. Zum Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung dieses Gesprächs könnte es sogar sein, dass es bereits öffentlich und verfügbar und herunterladbar ist. Wenn dem so ist, dann findet sich hier auf jeden Fall auch ein Link in den Shono zu dieser Sendung. Ich habe mich da freundlicherweise mal auch in die Beta-Version eingeladen. Ich finde das natürlich ganz pfiffig, dass man sozusagen, obwohl es alle erstmal gar nicht betrifft, trotzdem so ein einfaches Werkzeug in die Hand bekommt, dass man eben in dem Moment, wo man auch wirklich irgendwo vor Ort ist, eben genau diesen Tag ja letzten Endes setzen kann. Im Prinzip lässt es sich ja darauf reduzieren. Genau, richtig.
Also wir versuchen, die Komplexität der OpenStreetMap so runterzubrechen, dass diese eine Falle, ist ein Ort rollstuhlgerecht, ja oder nein, nutzerfreundlich bedient werden kann. Das kann man natürlich für tausend andere Dinge auch machen. Also man könnte jetzt sagen, Raucherkneipe, ja nein, Club Mate vorhanden, ja nein. Also irgendwie...
Also ob es nerdgerecht ist zum Beispiel.
Ja, so ungefähr.
Ja, zwar auch eine Behinderung.
Oder eine Gabe, man weiß es nicht.
Kann zur Einschränkung führen, auf jeden Fall.
Wenn man es nicht trinkt.
Und wenn man keine Club Mate hat. Dann funktioniert das nicht mehr so richtig. Ich hatte allerdings in dem Moment das Gefühl, jetzt muss ich sagen, das hast du ja schon angesprochen, ist es jetzt limited oder ist es nicht limited? Dann gab es eine ganze Reihe von Kategorien, an denen man das ausmachen kann. Ich hätte ja eigentlich sehr viel mehr Spaß gehabt. Ich habe jetzt wirklich jedes Detail, was mir so konkret auffällt, was ich aber in dem Moment nicht unbedingt in dem Kontext mit ist das Rollstuhl-gerecht bewerten muss. Zu sagen, dass da eine Stufe ist, die so und so hoch ist. Und wenn dann jemand anderes für mich die Auswertung, die Interpretation übernimmt, ob das nun gerecht ist. Weil ist ja auch nicht jeder Rollstuhl gleich.
Genau, aber wir haben ja dazu schon mal gesprochen im Zuge des Beta-Tests. Wir haben das auch noch mal intern diskutiert, ob man das vielleicht noch mal anders abfragen können müssen. Ob wir mit dem Launch der App warten sollten. Und haben dann aber eigentlich uns dafür entschieden zu sagen, wenn wir denken würden, wir sind ein Start-up. Also, dass er nicht unbedingt gewinnorientiert ist, aber von der Schlankheit, das Releasing von Software und der Weiterentwicklung und der irgendwie auch auf Nutzer hören, wollen wir eigentlich eher versuchen, Dinge so schnell wie möglich zu veröffentlichen und dann auf das Feedback zu reagieren und gucken. Gibt es vielleicht Dinge, die von der Prioritätenliste wichtiger sind?
Ja klar, das ist ja vollkommen nachvollziehbar. Zumal es ja auch klar ist, in dem Moment, wo es dieses akzeptierte Tag in der OpenStreetMap-Welt bereits gibt, wäre es ja geradezu ein Fehler, das sozusagen links liegen zu lassen, weil das ist sozusagen der least, wie sagt man, kommende Denominator. Also wenn man sich auf sonst nichts einigen kann, dann kann man sich zumindest darauf einigen und die offene Tag-Wolke von OpenStreetMap würde es ja in der Zukunft durchaus auch ermöglichen, weitere Tags sozusagen hineinzubringen, die konkreter sind.
Es gibt dafür auch schon einige, zum Beispiel für Hotels. Also speziell für Hotels gibt es nochmal, sind die Räume innen drin? Ist die Lounge rollstuhlgerecht? Wie breit sind die Türen? Also es geht dann noch viel weit gefächerte. Aber letztlich ist, sag mal, der Wheelchair-Tag an sich erst mal so, generell komm ich in das Gebäude rein.
Aber wer legt denn das fest? Also gibt es da so eine eigene Wheelchair-Tag-Community oder seid ihr da jetzt schon, habt ihr jetzt schon Definitionsmacht übernommen mit diesem Projekt?
Nee, Definitionsmacht. Wir haben uns hier eher unterworfen. Es gibt viele Uni-Projekte, die sich damit auseinandersetzen. Die Uni Heidelberg tut sich da mit Navigationen irgendwie relativ engagieren. Und es gibt auch die Uni München, die auch auf die OpenStreetMap setzt, die da auch irgendwie zu diesem Thema zumindest versucht hat, beizusteuern. Und wir reden natürlich auch mit vielen Rollstuhlfahrern zu diesem Thema. Wobei das Problem ist, das Thema kann ganz schnell ganz komplex werden. Also wir reden hier von Zentimeterbreiten bei Wendekreisen neben der Toilette links-rechts und Unterfahrbarkeit des Waschbeckens ja hinein. Ja, und Betthöhe im Hotel, Zimmer 207. Also das ist natürlich, wenn das die Behörden erfassen, dann gehen die mit 40-seitigen Fragebögen vorher angemeldet irgendwo hin und dauern, brauchen 2 Stunden, bis sie irgendwie das alles erfasst haben. Und wir sagen, ja, kann man machen, diese Daten sind sicherlich besser als, wenn irgendwie ein Standardnutzer das einträgt, aber man generiert keine Masse. Und auch relativ schwer Relevanz, weil die gehen ja dann eher in die Örtlichkeiten, die halt so eine Behörde für wichtig erachtet, aber das Berghain werden sie garantiert nicht erfassen, weil sich da ja auch kein Beamter reintraut. Also das ist so, wo wir einfach versuchen, dann auch das wieder auf eine Nutzbarkeit runterzubrechen. Und wir werden das sicherlich auch anecken in der Szene. Aber dann sollen die sich bitte einbringen. Also das ist jetzt unser Beitrag. Und wir sind natürlich für Ohren offen, haben offene Ohren für Verbesserungsvorschläge. Aber immer zu sagen, ja, das geht aber nicht weil, dann ist das immer ein Blocker.
Klar.
Aber letztlich gibt es ja in der OpenStreetMap diesen Proposal-Prozess. Da erstellt man einfach eine Wiki-Seite und sagt, ich hätte jetzt gerne einen neuen Tag, den würde ich so und so benennen, und mit denen und den Ausprägungen. Und der soll das und das transportieren. Und dann kann sich da alle Leute zu Wort melden und können sagen, das finden wir gut, das finden wir schlecht, oder das könnten wir besser machen. Und letztlich, vielleicht wird sich sowas entwickeln, wenn einfach die Wheelchair-Tags so weit verbreitet sind, dass es nicht nur graue Punkte gibt, sondern halt da viele bunte auf unserer Karte. Dass die Leute sagen, gut, das ist jetzt schon mal ein Grundrauschen, wir wissen die Orte, welche ich besuchen kann, aber es wäre jetzt noch schön, die und die Informationen zu haben. Und dann, mein Gott, hindert ja niemanden daran, neue Tags zu erfinden oder weitere Tag-Ausprägungen für Rollstuhlgerechtigkeit.
Und was wir halt auch jetzt schon anbieten, ist ein Kommentarfeld an jedem Ort, wo ich nicht sage, hm, der Kaffee ist hier besonders lecker, sondern wo ich sage, Cinemax, Potsdamer Platz ist rollstuhlgerecht, bis auf Kinosaal 3, 5 und 7. So, also der Information, die an jedem Ort eine andere sein kann, die man nicht mit Ja-Nein-Antworten beantworten kann.
Da hat man natürlich das Sprachproblem, in welcher Sprache trägt man es ein?
Selbst da könnte man ja das Kommentarfeld multilingual machen, also WheelchairDescriptionEN, wheelchairdescription.de und so weiter. Die Sprache, die wir auf Wheelmap einsetzen, ist initial Deutsch und Englisch, arbeiten aber auch schon an Spanisch, Französisch und sogar Japanisch.
Aber ihr seid ja sozusagen Sprachen, wo man sagen kann, ich schreibe es jetzt in Deutsch. Und andere Leute können das dann auch übersetzen. Okay, ja pfiffig. Was, ähm, blüm. Du hast schon erwähnt, es gibt bei Ämtern und Behörden durchaus auch 40-seitige Fragebögen mit denen Barrierefreiheit, jetzt im Bezug auf Rollstuhlfahrer oder eben auch andere Bayern, durchaus auch erfasst werden können. Das heißt, es gibt auch schon Daten. Ähm, ist das für euch nicht auch sehr interessant, bestehende Datenpools anzumuntern?
Also das ist das, was die Sozialhelden sich neben der reinen Entwicklung jetzt auf die Fahne schreiben. Das heißt, wir sind jetzt dabei und haben auch schon viele Gespräche geführt. Daten im großen Stil zu erheben, zu akquirieren. Das bedeutet, wir waren jetzt neulich beim Berliner Behindertenbeauftragten oder beim Berliner Beauftragten für Menschen mit Behinderung. So heißt das jetzt offiziell. Menschen immer zuerst, ganz wichtig. Genau. Und haben mit dem halt darüber geredet, Herr Zumeister, du hast jetzt irgendwie seit 10 Jahren eine schöne Datenbank, die du mit einem Euro-Job an befüllen lässt über einen Dienstleister. Wollen wir nicht zusammenarbeiten? Wir haben auch Daten. Wir könnten uns bestimmt super ergänzen. Die Doppelungen würden wir herausfiltern und mit den besseren Informationen auf uns oder eure anreichern. Und euch bieten wir an, eine Art Qualitätseintrag auf der Wheelmap zu markieren. Unter der Bedingung, dass das Ganze dann aber auch gemeinfrei wieder in die OpenStreetMap zurückgekippt werden kann, war er jetzt angetan von der Idee und hat auch, wie soll ich sagen, sich der Open Data eher bekannt, also mehr bekannt als wir dachten. Aber dahinter stecken natürlich auch viele rechtliche Fragen. Also er hat jetzt wie gesagt einen Dienstleister, der für ihn diese Daten mit 1-Euro-Jobbern erhebt. Das heißt, sowohl das Arbeitsamt hat Interesse an der Verwendung dieser Daten, weil sie ja die 1-Euro-Jobber finanzieren. Der Dienstleister hat Interesse an diesen Daten, weil sie ja letztendlich das Ganze koordinieren und die Termine mit den Besichtigungen machen. Der Auftraggeber ist aber der Berliner Beauftragte für Menschen mit Behinderungen. So dass es extrem interessante Interessen und juristische Fragen gibt, die wir jetzt versuchen, nach und nach mit denen zu klären. Also von wegen sein ganz implizites Interesse war, und das war dann auch im Gespräch rausgekommen, dass er will, dass diese beiden Projekte zusammenarbeiten. Das ist das Interesse, das er als Behindertenbeauftragter hat. Und wenn das nicht funktioniert, dann muss halt das Projekt, das er beauftragt, überlegen, sich gute Argumente überlegen, warum nicht? Warum funktioniert die Kooperation nicht? Und er war auch schon ein bisschen, wie soll ich sagen, auf unserer Seite gefühlt. Und diese Beobachtung machen wir halt an vielen Stellen. Also auch in anderen Städten werden diese Daten mit mühevoller Kleinstarbeit erhoben. Wir haben einen auf der Reha-Messe getroffen in Büsseldorf, der seit zwölf Jahren Orte erhebt. Und er hat in zwölf Jahren 4000 Orte erfasst, was ich persönlich jetzt einzeln betrachte, das 4000 viel, einzeln betrachtet, das zwölf Jahre viel. Aber in zwölf Jahren 4000 Orte ist jetzt nicht so viel. Also das generieren wir in drei Monaten. Oder in vier.
Na gut, aber die Datentiefe ist eine ganz andere.
Genau, aber die Datentiefe ist natürlich eine ganz andere.
Weil er sich sozusagen alles Mögliche anschaut.
Ja, wie gesagt, Betthöhe im Hotel und Wendekreis links, rechts an der Toilette. Aber es wirkte so ein bisschen, als ob es besessen, also da schon fast eine Besessenheit zu spüren. Und als wir ihn fragten, wollen wir die Daten nicht irgendwie austauschen und wir verlinken auf deine Detailtiefe, dann meinte er, ne, das geht nicht, die Daten kann man so nicht als Datendampf rüberspielen. Und ich fürchte, weil er das einzelne in HTML programmiert hat.
Ah, keine wirkliche Datenbank, sozusagen.
So sah jedenfalls die Seite am Ende auch aus. Aber er bekommt halt Geld von der Regierung, also von der Tourismuszentrale seiner Region. Ich will jetzt hier keine Namen nennen. Und das heißt, überall in Deutschland entstehen Datensilos, die dann mit Fördergeldern finanziert werden. Und die Dienstleister, die diese Daten halt erheben, hoffen, dass die Fördergelder über die nächsten zwei Jahre hinaus noch verlängert werden. Wenn aber nicht. Und das passierte beispielsweise in Niedersachsen nach der Expo 2000, wo man auch irgendwie 8000 Orte als Rollstuhl gerecht markiert hatte. Und die Expo war vorbei und das Messegelände war tot. Wurden natürlich auch die Daten nicht weiter gepflegt. Und das ist natürlich irgendwie aus Sicht der Daten und aus Sicht von Nerds wie uns ein extremes Mega-Fail. Also ich mein...
Ungerecht den Daten gegenüber.
Genau.
Man muss sie weiter pflegen.
Richtig. Und ich meine auch ungerecht...
Das ist wahrer Datenschutz. Man muss sich um die Daten kümmern.
Und das ist auch ungerecht den Leuten, die diese Daten mühsam erhoben haben. Also weil der Wert einfach verpufft. Und ich finde, ich sehe einfach aber auch wirklich kein Geschäftsmodell, zu sagen, ich verkaufe Daten, ob ein Ort reutschengerecht ist oder nicht, Geschäftsmodelle. Und das ist aber der Grund, warum es ständig diese juristischen Probleme gibt. Dass die Leute sagen, ja, aber wir könnten die Daten ja irgendwie mal irgendwann verwerten. Ja, könntet ihr. Aber es wird nie jemand geben, der euch diese Daten abkauft, weil dafür ist der Kundenstamm zu gering. Man könnte wahrscheinlich viel eher Geschäftsmodelle um Rollstuhlgerechtigkeit, Barrierefreiheit im weitesten Sinne stricken, indem man daran arbeitet, die zu lösen, die Probleme, die Barrierefreiheit betreffen.
Anstatt Daten zu verkaufen, wo drauf steht, hier sind überall Mauern.
Ja, genau. Also das ist einfach...
Einfach einreißen.
Genau, und daran arbeiten wir gerade. Wir missionieren auf einer gewissen Art und Weise erfolgreich, merken aber auch, wie weit viele Menschen auch noch zurück sind. Also wenn man sich anguckt, mit was für Computern Behindertenbeauftragte arbeiten und mit was für einer Personaldecke, wundert mich das natürlich nicht. Da nichts passiert. Das sind halt alte Krücken, die gerade mal Internet hatten. Und die surfen auch mal im Internet Explorer 6. Also das ist irgendwie so... Das ist halt ein Pain so.
So eBay-Ware. Hast du eigentlich eine Zahl im Kopf, wie viele Leute in Deutschland auf den Rollstuhl angewiesen sind?
1,6 Millionen.
1,6 Millionen? Das ist ja nicht wenig.
Ja, und es gibt 1,2 Millionen Blinde oder Menschen mit Sehbehinderung, dass man sagen kann, 9 bis 10 Prozent der Gesellschaft in Deutschland haben eine Behinderung.
Die für die Navigation in der Außenwelt relevant ist. Meinst du so eine Behinderung?
Behinderung ist dann ab einem Behinderungsgrad von 50 Prozent. Davon sind dann irgendwie 1,6 Rollstuhlfahrer, 1,2 blind. Es gibt ja noch mit Lernschwäche und so.
Das heißt, hast du jetzt schon alle Beispiele genannt an Datenquellen, die sozusagen bereits existieren? Was du jetzt genannt hast, sind ja so Projekte, wo genau so was Ähnliches getan wurde. Also explizit hin auf Behinderten, also Barrierefreiheit für Rollstuhlfahrer, sozusagen hin erfasst wurde und die man dann vielleicht übernehmen wollen würde, wenn sie denn in einer übernehmensfähigen Version überhaupt vorliegt. Gibt es denn auch noch andere Datenquellen, von denen ihr wisst, die unter Umständen gar nicht so explizit dafür gedacht sind, aber trotzdem unter Umständen eine gute Quelle darstellen könnten?
Also ein Beispiel nannte ich ja vorhin, das ist StreetView, die natürlich im Bild die Information enthalten, ob der Eingang eine Stufe hat oder nicht.
Na gut, aber das ist ja wahrscheinlich dann alles copyrighted und das kann man zwar anzeigen, aber das kann man ja nicht im eigentlichen Sinne verwenden.
Na ja, du könntest sie ja interpretieren. Das kann dir Google ja nicht verbieten.
Ach so, dass Leute drauf gucken und dann anfangen, das sozusagen in Daten umzuwandeln, was sie dort sehen.
Genau. Und dann gibt es natürlich, wie gesagt, auch die großen Ketten. Starbucks, McDonalds, wie sie auch alle heißen, böse oder nicht böse, die diese Daten haben, also diese Dinger ja mal gebaut haben und auch damals sich irgendwelchen Regeln im Sinne der Barrierefreiheit unterwerfen mussten, weil es neu bauten waren. Das heißt, diese Daten liegen vor, sind aber natürlich umständlich zu bekommen, weil es dann relativ schnell sehr kleinteilig wird.
Es gibt aber auch noch andere Datenquellen. Wir hatten neulich eine nette E-Mail von dem Stolperstein e.V. aus Hildesheim bekommen. Die hatten über alle sämtlichen Arztpraxen und Krankenhäuser diese Daten erfasst. Und zwar auch wirklich in der Datentiefe mit wie ist die Neigung der Rampe, wie breit sind die Türen und so weiter. Und die war total happy, einfach bei Wheelmap diese Daten auch mitvermerken zu können. Und die hat uns letztlich Daten geschenkt. Man hat die dann eingetragen. Und manchmal passt die Zeit auch so, dass Daten einfach zu uns kommen. Ohne, dass wir jetzt explizit danach fragen müssen.
Also wir haben auch zum Beispiel bei der BVG oder beim VBB angefragt, ob sie uns mal nicht alle ihre Gebäude geben könnten.
Also beim Verkehrsverbund Berlin Brandenburg. Jetzt mal hier für Leute, die nicht aus Berlin sind.
Und die haben, also wo wir erst dachten so, oh Gott, jetzt malen hier extrem lange Mühlen, kam irgendwie ein Tag später eine Mail, ja klar, wie braucht ihr die denn als Excel oder als XML? Okay. Dann haben wir halt irgendwie die Daten bekommen, und haben dann die importieren lassen in die OpenStreetMap. Und auf einmal sind jetzt irgendwie die Bahnhöfe drin. Also das ist, manchmal sind die...
Und welche Information über diese Bahnhöfe ist drin? Ist das jetzt wirklich nur dieses, ist behindertengerecht, ist nicht behindertengerecht, oder ist es dann schon mal so genauer?
Nee, nee, es ist halt Aufzug, ja, nein.
Das ist an der Stelle eigentlich entscheidend, ne?
Das heißt, die Daten sind ja sowieso kostenlos bei denen abrufbar, auf deren BVG planen. Aber es ist ja auch schön, sie auf der OpenStreetMap zu haben. Eine andere interessante Datenquelle ist natürlich auch Spezialportale, also Arztportale, Kinoportale, diese Information-Arbenstadt-Magazine, die man dann einfach... Also es wird dann technisch irgendwann ein Problem, wo man sagen muss, die Daten müssen irgendwie gematcht werden. Also es gibt diesen Ort bereits in der OpenStreetMap und es gibt diesen Ort bereits in der Ärzte-Datenbank. Sie schreiben sich vielleicht mit zwei Buchstaben anders, sind aber die gleichen eigentlich, mit Bindestrich, ohne Bindestrich, was auch immer. Wie sorgt man dafür, dass die Plattform erkennt, dass es das Gleiche ist? Und das sind die nächsten technischen Herausforderungen für Massen-Importe.
Wie kommen wir denn jetzt eigentlich ran an die Daten? Also wenn man jetzt auf Wheelmap-Org geht, dann sieht man im Wesentlichen so eine OpenStreetMap, wo dann eben Infrastructurelemente erscheinen, in so kleinen Sprechblasen-artigen Sachen. Das blendet ihr dann ein. Das ist da sozusagen schon euer Ding. Das heißt, man kann irgendwo draufklicken und dann sieht man dann halt, ob da sozusagen irgendwas zuvor liegt oder nicht.
Eigentlich ist auch das Icon auf der Karte farblich hinterlegt. Das heißt, grau ist unbekannt, grün ist...
Das heißt, man sieht es sozusagen schon. Genau.
Man kann sie auch filtern danach.
Indem man das sozusagen hier explizit ein- und ausfliegt, dass man die ganzen Unbekannten gleich weglässt.
Genau.
Und dann nur noch die über die Klarheit entsteht. Dann ist er aber dann schon deutlich dünner. Dann ist er sozusagen auch noch eine Menge zu holen.
Absolut. Wir sind auch erst seit anderthalb Monaten am Start.
Na klar, das Ganze ist ein frisches Projekt, aber trotzdem hat das ja auch schon so einige Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt. Ich denke, ich habe auch schon irgendeinen Preis... Ihr seid doch irgendwo aufgestellt, einen zu erhalten.
Genau, wir haben den Deutschen Bürgerpreis damit dieses Jahr gewonnen oder werden ihn gewinnen haben.
Deutscher Bürgerpreis, was ist das?
Das ist ein Preis, ein Zusammenschluss des Sparkassenverbandes und dem Städte- und Gemeinderat, irgendwie so. Die halt sich, also die schon seit ein paar Jahren den Bürgerpreis vergeben, wo es darum geht, Leute auch zu zeichnen, die sich engagieren. Und dieses Jahr stand das unter dem Motto helfen, glaube ich, oder helfen, schützen, Leben schenken, irgendwie so. Und wir helfen praktisch mit Wheelmap-Menschen im Alltag, im Rollstuhl zu überleben bzw. irgendwie klarzukommen. Und haben da den Publikumspreis gewonnen bei der Mindvz-Gruppe, der da irgendwie, wie soll ich sagen, wo man dort abstimmen konnte auf deren Plattformen. Na ja, verstehe. Ein klassisches Online-Voting. Kann man jetzt, ja, sich zu denken, was man möchte.
Na gut, ist halt ein Preis. Das hilft euch ja auch, Vorwärtsaufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen. Und ich weiß nicht, ist er irgendwie noch dotiert? Gibt es da irgendwie mehr als Ruh und Ehre?
Also der ist mit 5000 Euro dotiert, wo wir versuchen, dieses Geld natürlich in die Entwicklung sofort wieder reinzustecken. Weiterentwicklung von Wheelmap. Und der Sozialhelden e.V. finanziert sich auch bisher ausschließlich über Spenden und Wettbewerben. Und das ist praktisch jetzt ein Wettbewerb für dieses Projekt, womit wir das dann auch weiterführen. Letztes Jahr konnten wir das Ganze auch erst starten, weil wir letztes Jahr den deutschen Engagementpreis gewonnen, der mit 10.000 Euro, glaube ich, dotiert war. Und damit haben wir dann initial mit der Entwicklung angefangen. Also wir haben dann Programmierer bezahlt, die uns dann erstmal den Rohbau gemacht haben und konnten so dann auch mit Geofabrik zusammenarbeiten, weil natürlich auch nicht alle Leute umsonst für uns arbeiten können. Und die machen natürlich schon noch faire Preise und Special Deals. Aber wir wollen natürlich auch, dass die Arbeit wertgeschätzt wird.
Genau. Wie sieht es denn so technisch eigentlich so die Realität aus bei dem Projekt? Also sind jetzt erstmal alle Probleme gelöst? Ich weiß, dass du diesen Zustand nicht kennst, aber vielleicht könnt ihr ja mal kurz zusammenfassen, was funktioniert jetzt und was soll in Zukunft funktionieren?
Ja, was funktioniert jetzt? Der Import der relevanten Daten, die wir auf der Wheelmap anzeigen, funktioniert zuverlässig. Wir bekommen alle zwei Minuten ein Delta von den OpenStreetMap-Daten. Wir haben eine lokale Datenbank mit den relevanten Informationen für die Karte. Wir können die per API an unsere Web-Applikation und an die iPhone-Applikation ausliefern. Und wir können Änderungen und neue Daten entgegennehmen und speisen sie über eine API wieder zurück nach OpenStreetMap ein. Aber wie es am Anfang immer so ist, make it run, then make it fast. Es läuft jetzt. Wir sind jetzt inbegriffen, das Ganze noch ein bisschen schneller zu machen, wobei wir in den letzten zwei Wochen schon gute Erfolge erzielt haben. Und dann muss man auch mal ein bisschen mit der Hake durch den Code gehen und die Verwerfung, die man da so verbrochen hat, damit es erst mal funktioniert, natürlich nachträglich noch ein bisschen wieder gerade ziehen. Einfach, weil wenn man so komplett neu in so eine Thematik einsteigt, programmiert man halt auch Dinge, die so eigentlich nicht gedacht waren, auch von den Leuten, die die Bibliothek so anbieten. Und dann wird einem dann später auch klar, warum. Und dann muss man es halt auch mal wieder korrigieren. Und ja, so ein bisschen Gardening noch. Aber so die Grundfunktionalität steht eigentlich. Und wir sind damit auch eigentlich zufrieden.
Wo wollt ihr hin? Was ist da das The Big Picture? Und wo könnt ihr noch Hilfe gebrauchen, vor allem?
Also The Big Picture ist auf jeden Fall, dass wir eine Lösung finden, wie man Massenhaftraten importieren kann, ohne Dubletten in der OpenStreetMap zu erzeugen. Dann als nächstes kann man dieses Ding halt super ausbauen. Also man kann überlegen, baut man jetzt irgendwie Check-Ins ein, so wie bei Foursquare Places, keine Ahnung was. Oder fängt man an, irgendwie so eine Art Botschafter-Modell aufzubauen, wo man sagt, wir versuchen so eine Art Community-Spiel daraus zu machen. Wer hat die meisten Orte, in welcher Region getaggt und wird von wem verfolgt, so ungefähr. Man kann versuchen, so auch sogenannte barrierefrei Treffs zu organisieren. Dass man dann auch versucht, mit den Leuten, die diese Daten bereitstellen, irgendwie in Kontakt zu treten und zu sagen, wir wollen auch alle das Gleiche. Wir wollen eben nicht nur Daten erheben, sondern vielleicht auch dafür sorgen, dass Orte, die bisher nicht rollstuhlgerecht werden, was kann man tun, dass man auch in so eine Richtung mal denkt, was dann aber schnell wieder offen wird praktisch. Und natürlich ist es auch so, dass, wie soll ich sagen, iPhone ist schön und gut, kann man machen. Wir wissen aber auch irgendwie, wie viele Prozent haben denn eigentlich ein iPhone und wie viele Prozent besitzen in Wirklichkeit ein Nokia-Handy? Und irgendwie, warum gibt es Wheelmap noch nicht auf einem Nokia-Handy? Und warum gibt es Wheelmap noch nicht auf einem Android-Handy? Und wo auch immer. Und da bräuchten wir immer irgendwie Support im Sinne von, fürs iPhone entwickeln ist leichter bisher als für andere Anwendungen. Weil wir auch selber alle iPhones besitzen, sag ich jetzt mal. Und das irgendwie so in unserer Realität stattfindet. Aber wir wissen auch da draußen eben nicht zwangsläufig. Und das heißt, ist es jetzt sinnvoll, eine Mobile-Website zu haben? Oder bräuchten wir jetzt für jedes Gerät eine eigene Software? Und all sowas sind jetzt Dinge, an die wir versuchen, uns ranzutasten. Aber irgendwie auch ohne uns zu überheben oder zu verheben. Weil wir eben wie gesagt auch immer von der Hand in den Mund leben. Also das ist ja fast alles Ehrenamt, was wir machen.
Also ihr könnt noch Programmierer gebrauchen. Aber ihr könnt auch Daten gebrauchen.
Genau, also Daten sind glaube ich wichtiger. Programmierer sind auch wichtig. Man muss sie halt entsprechend verknüpfen, koordinieren, verbinden. Und dann auch wirklich versuchen, sie nicht einzeln zu überlasten.
Aber was für Daten stehen dir sozusagen auf eurer Wunschliste ganz oben?
Also am geilsten wäre es natürlich, dass sich alle Leute da draußen irgendwie die iPhone App runterladen, wenn sie ein iPhone haben und selbstständig ihre Gegend taggen. Mediale Aufmerksamkeit ist innerhalb der Zielgruppe auch interessant. Also Rollstuhlfahrer direkt erreichen, die ja dann viel größeren Nutzen aus der Plattform ziehen. Also ich selber benutze inzwischen schon Wheelmap, um zu gucken, wo kann ich denn am hackischen Markt eigentlich einen Kaffee trinken. Weil ich habe da zwei Jahre lang gearbeitet, habe mir aber nie die Orte angeguckt und inzwischen kenne ich drei, vier.
Und funktioniert das für dich?
Ja, das funktioniert.
Wie ist das so, das Gefühl?
Ich finde es irgendwie lustig, dass irgendwie das eigene Ding, das man gebaut hat, plötzlich auch einem selber hilft. Das hatte ich erst die letzten zwei Wochen, dieses Erlebnis. Und ich finde es irgendwie cool. Das Tolle an der OpenStreetMap ist ja auch, es gibt da draußen angeblich 300.000 Mapper. Und diese 300.000 Mapper, denen ist es egal, ob sie einen Strommast mappen, einen Briefkasten oder die Barrierefreiheit eines Ortes. Und wir wollen eigentlich innerhalb dieser Community auch werben, dass das eine relevante Information sein kann, ohne jetzt zu sagen, die ist relevanter als ein Strommast, aber irgendwie auch relevant. Wobei, ja.
Gut, Daten kommen halt jetzt auch schon rein, ne? Jeden Tag werden im Durchschnitt 40 neue Orte in der Datenbank als rollstuhgerecht oder halt nicht rollstuhgerecht markiert. Aber es könnte halt mehr sein. Wir freuen uns natürlich über jeden, der da mitmacht.
Ihr habt ja eine eigene User Base, ne? Wie stark ist die jetzt so nach der Beta-Phase?
Also man kann, wenn man einen eigenen Ort anlegen will, dann muss man sich bei uns registrieren. Wenn man den Status eines Ortes ändert, muss man sich nicht registrieren. Das ist auch im Sinne der Usability gedacht, um den Einstieg so gering wie möglich, also die Barriere so gering wie möglich zu halten, sich zu beteiligen an der Plattform.
Das heißt, so ein bisschen wie Wikipedia, neuer Artikel, erfordert Account sozusagen.
Genau, genau, genau.
Man muss aber auch noch einen Account bei OpenStreetMap haben, ne?
Ja, da ist jetzt ein Punkt, an dem wir jetzt gerade überlegen, wie kann man das noch vereinfachen? Also dass man nur einen Account braucht, oder dass man vielleicht gar keinen braucht, oder was auch immer, um es noch simpler zu machen.
Ich glaube, in unserer Datenbank wirklich registrierte User sind 40, maximal 50. Aber die meisten müssen sich halt nicht registrieren, die müssen sich nicht anmelden, einfach um einen Ort zu markieren. Deswegen können wir es halt auch nicht wirklich beziffern, wie viele Leute da mitnehmen.
Wir wollen auch kein eigenes Social Network aufbauen. Also weil davon gibt es da draußen genug. Sondern es soll einfach darum gehen, eben regelkonform mit der OpenStreetMap Daten zu erheben, ohne gleich als Spammer bei denen irgendwie gelistet zu werden, weswegen wir Nutzer-Accounts brauchen. Also das ist eigentlich die Richtung, warum wir Nutzer-Accounts anlegen müssen. Aber wir haben halt gesagt, niedrigschwellige, kritische Informationen wie Barrierefreiheit, ja, nein, kann, wenn sie ohne Nutzer-Namen erhoben werden, jetzt kein Spam sein. Es wäre halt ein Spam, wenn ich überall Orte, Tags eintrage.
Was ich generell bei diesen Diensten bei OpenStreetMap insbesondere immer als Schwierigkeit angesehen habe, ist so, man sieht ja immer nicht so richtig, was noch gar nicht da ist. Ja, also so dieses, was könnte man denn eigentlich noch erfassen, das bietet sich einem so nicht an, weil es eigentlich erst in dem Moment auftaucht und sichtbar gemacht wird, wo es eben da ist. Gibt es irgendwie Methoden, wie man so eine Abschussliste, die man irgendwie vorgesetzt bekommt, man könnte die Leute ja so quasi auf so einer Schnitzeljagd durch die Straßen schicken, weißt du, um einfach sozusagen die fehlenden Punkte abzuhaken.
Genau, das sind dann sogenannte Mapping-Parties, die kann man initiieren, die werden auch initiiert. Ich glaube, im November sind wir auf dem OpenStreetMap-Blog ein Tagging-Projekt. Das heißt, da würde es dann darum gehen, dass Menschen, die an der OpenStreetMap arbeiten, aufgerufen werden, Barrierefreiheit zu taggen.
Also ist das sozusagen auch explizit das Thema?
Genau, es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, die OpenStreetMap auszudrucken und dann auf ein Klemmbrett durch die Stadt zu gehen und Orte mit einem Kuli auf dieses Papier zu schreiben, anschließend wieder einzuscannen. Und irgendjemand da draußen in dieser verrückten OpenStreetMap-Community-Welt wird dann diese Daten digitalisieren. Oder man selber, je nachdem.
Da ist so ein QR-Code drauf und damit weiß OpenStreetMap hinter welches Karten-Ausschnitt das sozusagen hintergelegt wird. Dann kann es halt jeder nehmen. Er nimmt sich das kleine Gekritzel und sagt, ah, das ist ein Ort, er heißt so und so. Und kann es halt selber eintragen, ohne dass er jemals selbst vor Ort gewesen ist.
Und wir waren halt, das ist das Interessante, wir waren vor ein paar Monaten in Girona bei der Straight State of the Map OpenStreetMap-Konferenz 2010. Und das ist halt sehr, sehr interessant gewesen. Also das sind halt klassische OpenStreetMapper gewesen aus der ganzen Welt, die dann sich in Spanien in einem Konferenzraum trafen für drei Tage.
Italien?
Nee, Spanien. Girona.
Ach, Girona.
Und dort haben wir uns praktisch zum ersten Mal mit der OpenStreetMap-Community auch in real life befasst, sehr nette Menschen, die uns ein bisschen als Jünger gesehen haben. Also die fanden es toll, dass neue Menschen dazukamen, die jetzt keinen mega Nerd-Faktor hatten.
Menschen, die eine richtige Anwendung haben.
Und die drängten uns dann auch dazu, dass wir dann dort mal den Social Cause, also den sozialen Zweck von unserem Projekt auch präsentieren und sollten dann da irgendwie innerhalb von drei Minuten eine Präsentation zusammenzimmern und die dann auch halten. Was wir dann auch gemacht haben. Da haben wir dann Frederik Ramm kennengelernt. Und das ist halt sehr, wie soll ich sagen, eine sehr nette, sehr liebevolle Community, die einfach die Zeichen der Zeit erkannt hat, zu sagen, es ist einfach wichtig, ein Pendant zu Wikipedia auf Kartenbasis aufzubauen. Und es ist egal, was wir tragen, es ist einfach nur wichtig, dass man es kann, dass es geht und dass es möglichst alles geht. Und Wheelmap auf Basis der OpenStreetMap ist ein Fall, der medial gut funktioniert. Das ist auch denen klar. So wie HIDI denen einfach gut zugespielt hat, um die OpenStreetMap bekannt zu machen. Spielt auch Wheelmap im urbanen, westländischen Raum den Medien gut zu und auch der OpenStreetMap.
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall erkennbar und nachvollziehbar, was da sozusagen Ziel ist und wie man es macht. Bei CRE seid ihr jetzt auch.
Also wir können eigentlich nur Leute dazu aufrufen und ermuntern, wenn sie sich mit der OpenStreetMap beschäftigen oder auch nicht, Orte als barrierefrei zu markieren oder auch nicht. Bei unserem Ziel ist es, irgendwann eine Liste zu haben von Orten, die nicht Rollstuhlgerecht sind und dann auch ein Druckmittel zu haben. Also dann auch politisch aktiv werden zu können, dann auch vielleicht zu den einzelnen Ketten zu gehen und zu sagen, Leute, 24 eurer Deutsche Bank-Filialen in Berlin sind nicht Rollstuhlgerecht. Das kann doch eigentlich nicht sein. Und dann einfach auch mal wirklich Argumente zu bekommen, die dann auch wirklich ge-Krautsaust wurden. Wie oft wird man denn vertröstet, egal ob im Rollstuhl oder nicht, von irgendwelchen langweiligen Call-Center-Angestellten, die dann einfach sagen, ja, wir arbeiten dran, ich gebe das weiter, wir kümmern uns drum, es tut uns leid, gehen Sie doch in eine andere Filiale. Also einfach Antworten, die einem nicht weiterhelfen. Und in den USA kann man sowas einklagen, in Deutschland leider nicht, und vielleicht muss man zu anderen Mitteln greifen.
Ja, was man nicht rechtlich einklagen kann, das kann man dann gegebenenfalls medial eintrommeln.
Genau.
Mit dem Pranger.
Die sogenannte Blacklist, genau.
Die Metaebene ist leider auch nicht uneingeschränkt rollstuhlgerecht.
Ja gut, aber das ist jetzt auch eher ein, wie soll ich sagen, ein privater Raum.
Ja, man muss ja auch trotzdem noch dran arbeiten.
Kann man machen, ist jetzt, glaube ich, nicht ganz so wichtig wie die Sparkasse bei mir in der Ecke.
Das kann ich mir auch vorstellen. Na gut, haben wir noch etwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen. Mit an Preisen mangelt es euch ja gar nicht. Was ist diese Ashoka-Geschichte, die da jetzt noch für dich demnächst ansteht? Kannst du das nochmal erwähnen?
Ja, Ashoka ist eine Stiftung, die weltweit Stipendiaten aus, äh, wie? Kürt, genau. Die versuchen, an einem sozialen Wandel zu arbeiten. Also in dem Fall wäre jetzt bei mir der soziale Wandel, diese Welt für Rollstuhlfahrer ein kleines bisschen erträglicher zu machen und das idealerweise sogar messbar. Und diese Stiftung kümmert sich halt darum, dass Menschen wie ich, die sich irgendwie diesen sozialen Wandel verschrieben haben, finanziell unter die Arme zu greifen, indem sie es ihnen ermöglichen, drei Jahre lang 100 Prozent ihrer Arbeitszeit in dieses Projekt zu stecken. Und dann praktisch Lebensunterhalt oder das, was halt fehlt, zu finanzieren. So eine Art Grundeinkommen, genau. Das ist natürlich auf einem Solidaritätsprinzip basiert. Also es geht nicht darum, möglichst viele abzusahen, sondern es geht darum, das, was man braucht, zu bekommen. Und je weniger man braucht, desto mehr Leute kann diese Stiftung halt unterstützen. Und das ist insofern eine sehr interessante Geschichte, weil man irgendwie auch mit Leuten vernetzt wird über diese Stiftung, die sich ähnlichen Zielen verschrieben haben, auf anderen Teilen der Welt zum Beispiel. Und die sorgen halt für diese Vernetzung innerhalb der Leute. Und da sie von einer relativ großen Unternehmensberatung mehr oder weniger initiiert wurden vor Jahren, gibt es auch sehr große Kontakte nach oben, oder gute Kontakte nach oben zu Unternehmen, Konzernen, die einem dann entweder auch über, sogar Politikern, die dann einem entweder finanziell unter die Arme greifen, mit Daten unter die Arme greifen, mit Lobby unter die Arme greifen. Das, was man halt anfordert, wird dann halt versucht zu ermöglichen. Aber man darf sich da jetzt auch nicht irgendwie erhoffen, na, jetzt ist alles geritzt, sondern Arbeit bleibt es weiterhin, nachher anzuarbeiten. Und ich freue mich auf diese Chance, weil ich glaube, es gibt da draußen viele Dateninhaber. Und wenn es Mavi-Gerätehersteller sind oder was auch immer, die sowieso alle zwei Tage durch die Stadt rennen und neue Points of Interest erfassen, warum kann man denen nicht auch irgendwie mit denen zusammenarbeiten? Also ich glaube, es gibt eine Menge da draußen gelbe Seiten, um jetzt mal irgendwie ein paar wirklich große Adresshändler zu haben. Warum kann man nicht mit denen zusammenarbeiten?
Ja, warum nicht?
Ja, daran arbeiten wir.
Und wer jetzt hier zugehört hat und noch ein paar Geodaten rumliegen hat, die vielleicht fürs Projekt relevant sein könnten. Oder irgendwelche Plattformen gerne programmiert, die sich unter Umständen hier mal mit einer Wheelmap-Applikation oder einer mobilen Webseite beglücken lassen. Der sei durchaus aufgefordert, sich zu melden, und zwar bei wo, wie was, Webseite, tralala, wie, wo seid ihr eigentlich gelandet.
Genau, zu erreichen sind wir alle unter www.sozialhelden.de, E-Mail-Adresse info at socialhelden.de. Und man kann sich ja aber auch über Kontaktformular bei uns melden, beziehungsweise über Facebook. Ach, alles.
Facebook.
Die Handynummer gebe ich jetzt nicht raus, aber die Handynummer habe ich jetzt extra von der Webseite genommen.
Ja, Twitter, tralala, da steht ja auch alles in der Liste. Gut, haben wir was Wichtiges vergessen?
Christoph, hast du noch was? Wir treffen uns, das ist vielleicht noch eine kleine Anekdote, wir haben kein Büro, worauf wir auch stolz sind. Weil wir sagen, so ein Büro...
Spieße ich.
Also so ein Büro braucht man halt nur, wenn man irgendwie, keine Ahnung, auch einen festen Arbeitsplatz hat, der noch nicht existent ist. Das heißt, wir organisieren uns sowieso alle übers Internet. Das heißt, man braucht auch kein schlechtes Gewissen haben, wenn man uns nur eine E-Mail schreibt und nicht anruft. Es ist sogar das bessere Medium, weil wir einfach alle immer woanders sind und die E-Mail das einzige Beständige praktisch nach außen ist, über das man uns erreichen kann. Das wir aber auch bearbeiten und pflegen und regelmäßig fast stündlich einsehen. Und wir organisieren uns halt so, dass wir versuchen, feste Arbeitstermine zu haben. Das ist einmal im Monat alle Sozialhelden zusammen, wo wir dann versuchen, wie soll ich mal sagen, Vereinsmeierei abzufristücken. Also Satzung, Steuer, all der ganze Kram halt, mit dem man ungern zu tun hat. Und sonst eher so Projekttreffen initiiert. Bei Wheelmap ist es einmal die Woche, dass wir uns im Betahaus treffen, in Berlin, am Moritzplatz, da unten im Café, wo man eben auch keine Miete zahlt und es aber kostenlose WLAN gibt. Und dort treffen wir uns dann für ein paar Stunden und arbeiten die nächsten Punkte im P-Bottle-Tracker ab, die so als Bugs und Feature-Requests eingegangen sind. Und dann ist Wochenende und dann geht wieder jeder nach Hause und testet dann. Und dann Montag geht das Ganze mit so einem Rumgemäle wieder los, bis man sich Freitag wieder trifft und wieder die Sachen abarbeitet.
Also, wenn man in Touch geraten will, dann kann man auch da bei den Treffen auch tauchen.
Genau, er sollte vorher eine Mail schreiben, damit wir uns entweder Zeit nehmen bzw. auch wirklich da sind. Aber bisher waren wir die letzten Monate jeden Freitag da.
Genau, und den Rest der Woche hat jeder irgendwie einen anderen Job.
Genau, also ich arbeite bei Radio Fritz, du arbeitest...
Bei Better Place, genau, online Spendenportal, auch hier in Berlin.
Jetzt wagt jeder sozusagen die Zeit ab, die er hat.
Genau.
Für die Sozialhelden. Na super. Ihr Sozialhelden. Na, haben wir es, wa? Das war es.
Danke für die Einladung.
Ja, danke fürs Kommen und fürs Schildern usw. Und danke auch für die Anwendung. Ich finde es ja super, auch wenn ich jetzt so selbst davon nicht betroffen bin. Andererseits merke ich halt auch immer wieder, dass kann es einem ja dann auch ermöglichen, was weiß ich, wenn man jetzt irgendwie ein Meeting einberufen möchte, wo dann halt auch Leute im Rollstuhl einfach dabei sind. Das ist ja dann irgendwie auch immer das Letzte, woran man denkt. Und selbst wenn man dann halt daran denkt, dann hat man wiederum auch keine... Weil man ja gerade die Erfahrung nicht hat und selbst wenn man den Laden kennt, eben einfach da auch die Scheibe vorm Hirn hat und einfach, ja, weiß nicht, sind da jetzt Stufen am Eingang? Keine Ahnung, nimmt man nicht wahr. Man geht da einfach rein und dann ist man halt irgendwie drin. So, nee, ich hatte eigentlich keine Probleme, da reinzukommen. Dann schaut man sich das halt irgendwie noch mal näher an und dann merkt man so, na ja, alles klar. Und da hinten die Klos, noch mal eine Treppe und keine Ahnung, oder enger Flur und enger Gang. Und Klos sind ja eh meistens recht platzsparend ausgelegt, nicht wahr?
Was mir als Rollstuhlfahrer in solchen Situationen immer passiert, dass ich immer so, also für mich ist es ein sehr unangehendes Gefühl, wenn ich Menschen darauf aufmerksam mache, also indirekt darauf aufmerksam mache, dass sie vielleicht da nicht dran gedacht haben. Also angenommen, du würdest jetzt ein Treffen organisieren und ich würde dich dann zwei Stunden vorher fragen, ist der Ort Rollstuhlgerecht oder nicht, dass du dann plötzlich so ein Schuldgefühl bekommst, weil du nicht dran gedacht hast. Was aber gar nicht meine Intention war, sondern meine Intention war eigentlich nur, welchen Rollstuhl soll ich mitbringen, so ungefähr. Das kleine schwarze oder den großen roten. Und das sorgt irgendwie immer für Beklemmung. Das ist mir sehr unangenehm, da so eine Art Bitsteller-Funktion zu haben, die auf der anderen Seite ein schlechtes Gewissen provoziert. Aber das ist leider so.
Ja, deswegen ist natürlich die Datenbank dann auch eine Hilfe. So, dass man sozusagen weiß, tra-la-la, so sieht es aus. Fahrschul vorhanden, alles immer.
Interessant vor allem...
Ich hätte aber trotzdem gerne noch dieses Super-Expert-Modus-Teil, wo ich dann irgendwie auch jeden Scheiß eintragen kann. Also ich meine, gerade so die Daten-Nerds, die Jäger und Sammler, die wir hier auch schon ein bisschen angesprochen haben, die geben sich natürlich dann mit so etwas wie, ist Rollstuhl gerecht, ist nicht Rollstuhl gerecht? Weiß ich nicht, da fühle ich mich nicht ausreichend herausgefordert.
Aber die können ja dann auch direkt in der OpenStreetMap alles taggen.
Ja gut, aber dann wird es halt wieder schwierig, weil was ist dann so das richtige Tag? An der Stelle finde ich halt gerade sowas wie Wheelmap wäre dann für mich so der richtige Proxy. Verstehst du, wo sozusagen so die Komplexität der Datenspeicherung so weit umgebrochen wird, dass ich sagen kann, okay, ich kann jetzt hier auch noch diesen und diesen und diesen Aspekt auch noch mit reinbringen und die Software, die kümmert sich darum, dass das auch alles richtig in der Datenbank landet, nicht, dass ich da noch irgendwas kaputt mache. Das ist ja auch immer so eine Befürchtung, wenn man sich damit selten beschäftigt. Aber bevor ich jetzt irgendwie so ein Casual-Game im Bahnhof starte, weißt du, und mich da irgendwie noch mal mit 10 Minuten Tetris beim Warten auf den Zug stumpf mache, dann kann ich ja auch irgendwie so auf Datenspuren gehen und hier noch mal ein bisschen, weißt du, was erfassen und dann.
Ich fände das interessant. Ja, da hast du recht. Daran könnte man auch mal denken. Wobei ich glaube, wenn man wirklich die Masse will, dann müsste man eher in so einen Foursquare-Modus rein. Also wo man sagt, ich checke gerade hier ein und im Übrigen ist der Ort nicht Rollstuhlgerecht.
Ja, das wäre wohl wieder was für Foursquare selber.
Ich benutze Foursquare wirklich, um kaputte S-Bahn-Aufzüge einfach in diesen Foursquare-Feed reinzukriegen. Also dass die Leute, die das vielleicht lesen, ich bin inzwischen der Bürgermeister oder Mayor von S-Bahnhof Griebnitzsee, weil der einfach ständig kaputte Aufzüge hat. Und ich meine, der nächste, der dann dort eincheckt, der bekommt dann zumindest dafür einen Blick. Ich will ja nicht, dass er das Problem löst.
Also du checkst einen, um zu sagen, dass er Foursquare nicht gibt? Genau. Ach so, verstehe.
Eigentlich Hacking schon fast. Aber vielleicht kann man so auch für Aufmerksamkeit sorgen.
Ich glaube, ich meine allein schon so eine Statistik mit, wer hat am meisten rollstuhlgerechte Orte getaggt. Das wäre, glaube ich, schon mal so eine Herausforderung. Das hat ja bei der Wikipedia auch lange gehalten, so mit irgendwie, wer das hast du denn und so.
Oder auch Facebook Places ist ja ein prima Tool, um da, wie soll ich sagen, anzudocken. Anzudocken, genau. Was ich noch interessant finde, ich habe gerade mein Diplom geschrieben zum Thema im Allgemeinen Menschen mit Behinderung in den deutschen Medien und habe mich da sehr viel mit Disability Studies auseinandergesetzt. Und dann neben dieser ganzen Genderfrage... Ne, Disability. Disability ist ein Unterzweig der Gender Studies, wo es halt darum geht, was ist Behinderung eigentlich? Ist Behinderung praktisch nicht behindert? Oder also, wo fängt Behinderung an? Wo hört normal auf? Oder nicht behindert? Das ist ja eigentlich nur Definitionsfragen. Und daher habe ich ein sehr interessantes Zitat gelesen von einem Aktivisten aus den USA. Und der sagt, es gibt nicht die Bipolarität behindert, nicht behindert, sondern in seinen Augen gibt es nur die Aussage behindert und zeitweise nicht behindert. Das heißt, als Kind sind wir behindert, weil wir einen Vormund haben, weil wir klein sind, weil wir schwach sind, weil wir bestimmte Dinge einfach nicht können, weil die Welt zu komplex ist. Und als alte Menschen werden wir wieder behindert, weil wir schwach werden, weil wir vielleicht Rollator brauchen, weil wir krank werden, was auch immer. Und insofern geht es nicht mehr darum zu sagen, ja nein, es geht darum, ich habe das Glück, irgendwie 30 Jahre meines Lebens, 40 Jahre meines Lebens, alles selbstständig zu können, aber davor und danach irgendwie brauche ich wieder Hilfe. Und das finde ich einen interessanten Gedankengang, gepaart mit der Aussage, dass auch Nicht-Behinderte ein Recht haben, mit Behinderten zusammenzuleben. Das heißt, bisher ist es ja so in Deutschland, dass Menschen mit Behinderung eher verwaltet werden. Das heißt, sie kommen in Förderschulen, sie kommen in Förderzentren, gehen in Reha-Häuser, machen Therapie und arbeiten am Ende in Behindertenwerkstätten und werden mit dem Telebus von A nach B gefahren. Aber sie tauchen im Stadtbild so gut wie gar nicht auf. Und auch Menschen, die nur körperlich behindert sind. Also wir reden hier nicht nur von schwerst-mehrfach-Behinderten oder Menschen, die vielleicht erhöhten Förderbedarf haben, sondern es geht wirklich auch um Regionen in Deutschland, die noch nicht mal ländlich sein müssen, also auch Großstädte, wo das noch so betrieben wird. Auch Berlin teilweise, die da aber schon relativ weit von weggehen. Sodass ich einfach auch immer sage, auch nicht-Behinderte haben ein Recht, mit Behinderten zusammenzuleben. Und es ist einfach immer eine Frage, wie man die Sache halt betrachtet.
Ja, es ist immer eine Frage, wie man die Dinge betrachtet.
Genau.
Hier betrachten wir sie dann immer im Detail.
Und technisch.
Und technisch. Und auch gesellschaftlich und auch kulturell und überhaupt. Und Spaß haben wir auch noch dabei. So, bei Chaosradio Express. Und das war's jetzt auch. Vielen Dank, Christoph. Vielen Dank, Rául.
Gerne.
Für die Ausführungen hier zu Wheelmap. Und ihr da draußen, ich hoffe, ihr guckt euch das mal an. Klickt mal ein bisschen, irgendwie erfasst mal die eine oder andere Treppe. Mal gucken. Crowdsourcing heißt das Stichwort hier. Und ich denke, da kann eigentlich eine Menge gehen. Wenn man jetzt mal hier diesen Schritt mit dem Login da einmal hinter sich gebracht hat, dann kann man halt auch schnell neue Orte erfassen und so. Also wenn ein iPhone hat...
Lass uns die große Datenbank Deutschlands zu dem Thema werden.
Ist ja nicht mal unsere...
Deutschlands. Warum so kleindenken?
Intergalaktisch.
Morgen das Sonnensystem.
Universum und der ganze Rest.
Gut, dann mache ich jetzt hier mal Schluss und Decke drauf. Danke nochmal und danke auch fürs Zuhören. Und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.